[Music]
we also want
to bring europe closer to the citizens and
we have achieved a milestone, namely that we
were able to accept the brussels ordinance today in which all members of
this brussels ordinance have
agreed
mb are more writes in the interests of the
children a bit of the  step especially
for users who need special support
and a topic that we
hear again and again is uwe lenz that means
electronic evidence that hate always
takes
place on the internet child pornography also takes place in this
case when other
crimes are committed on the internet and there is always the
problem of how  let's get down to this
electronic evidence and,
accordingly, to hold the polluters
responsible.
we have also succeeded in achieving a
general orientation today, so
that we can now enter into discussions with the
european parliament
with the aim that we
are faster in this area and  accordingly we can fight the internet and
hate on the net
more effectively